capacité des pays dotés donc clairement
nous on a développé ce programme
simulation qui est adossé comme vous
l'aurez compris à la fois sur 210 de
séries nucléaires du passé qui nous
permet à la fin d'avoir la meilleure
évaluation possible du niveau de
confiance donc de l'incertitude de
l'outil numérique
et puis bien entendu des grands
instruments les supercalculateurs le
laser un megajoul et pur si on regarde
ce que font les autres pays dotés les
États-Unis ont un laser qui est
équivalent au notes c'est la National
facility qui est à liver mort en
Californie ils ont des installations et
des machines radiophiques l'eau salamos
cite du Nevada
les brittes dépendent des Américains
donc ils ont pas avoir toutes ces
installations là et puis pour les
Chinois on n'a aucun contact et chez les
Chinois et avec les russes depuis 2014
on a pu non plus au moment on a arrêté
nos contacts avec les Russes sur
décision de l'Élysée
ils avaient dans leur carton de réaliser
un laser qui serait équivalent laser
mégajoules ou au NIF américain et des
machines radiographiques qu'ils en
avaient puisqu'on le savait voilà donc
ils ont à peu près les après en termes
de cellulaires les années les États-Unis
en ont réalisé 1051 et la Russie l'Union
soviétique pardon un peu plus de 700
alors il y a un fait quand même qui est
majeur dans votre question et dans ma
réponse c'est que la France a renoncé
définitivement des cellucléaires on a
démoclés si tu Pacifique les quatre
autres pays enfin les trois puisque les
anglais sont besoin de faire des
saisiront Nevada les trois autres pays
ont conservé intacte leur moyen des
cellucléaires de tester des faire des
essais du coeurs et en particulier dans
le vouliez si vous lisez le rapport des
rapports de congrès du Congrès américain
qui sont extrêmement détaillés vous
verrez dans leur dans le budget
américain et prévu chaque année la
préparation de la décès nucléaire au cas
où c'est un peu ce qu'a fait la France
en 92 avec le moratoire décidé par le
président Mitterrand on a continué à
préparer un essai nucléaires sans tir er
mais les Américains gardent cette
compétence là vivante bien entendu je
pense c'est un avis personnel le poids
politique sera tel je pense qu'ici
amuseront pas mais cela dit tous les
autres pays dotés ont la possibilité de
réaliser ces nucléaires ce à quoi nous
nous avons définitivement renoncé